En un video anterior presentamos la noción de
enlace entre átomos y hablamos sobre los tipos
de enlaces iónico, covalente y metálico.
En este video vamos a profundizar un poco
más en esto y hablaremos sobre los tipos de
enlaces que podrían formarse entre diferentes
elementos. Y para entenderlo, voy a presentar
una clasificación amplia de los elementos. En
general sólo pensaremos en metales y no metales,
incluso antes de señalar en la tabla periódica de
elementos cuáles son los metales, cuáles son los
no metales y cuáles son los que están en el medio,
digamos cuáles son las propiedades de los
metales. Bueno, en general conducen la
electricidad -conducen electricidad-, tienden a
ser maleables, lo cual es una forma elegante de
decir que puedes doblarlo sin romperlos y, en
general, son sólidos a temperatura ambiente,
aunque hay excepciones, así que diré que
son sólidos a temperatura ambiente. Ahora,
¿cuál crees que son las propiedades de los no
metales? En general van a ser lo contrario de
esto. Los no metales normalmente no son sólidos
a temperatura ambiente, a menudo son gases,
no van a conducir bien electricidad. Ahora,
cuando miras una tabla periódica de elementos,
¿cómo se dividen los metales de los no metales?
Bueno, lo voy a indicar con esta pequeña línea
amarilla: todo lo que está arriba y a la derecha
de esta línea amarilla es un no metal, y si nos
fijamos en el código de color de las personas que
hicieron esta tabla periódica de elementos, todo
lo que está en este color amarillo que tenemos
aquí, el hidrógeno, carbono, nitrógeno, oxígeno,
flúor, cloro, y podría seguir, todos estos son
no metales, y éstos generalmente a temperatura
ambiente estarán en forma de gas y no conducirán
bien la electricidad. Estos que están en azul, y
de los que hemos hablado en otros videos, son los
gases nobles, también son no metales. Las personas
que hicieron esta tabla periódica de elementos
les pusieron su propio color, así podrías verlos
como una subclase de los no metales. Tienden a
ser muy inertes, no interactúan con otras cosas,
no tienden a formar ninguno de estos enlaces.
Ahora, puedes considerar que todo lo demás de
alguna forma es un metal y la razón por la cual
esta tabla periódica de elementos tiene diferentes
colores es porque hay subclasificaciones de los
metales, pero en términos generales todas estas
cosas que ves aquí debajo de esta línea amarilla
tienen las propiedades de conducir electricidad,
ser maleables, ser sólidos a temperatura
ambiente, y estos elementos que se extienden
alrededor de la línea amarilla que están en
este otro color a veces se ven como metaloides,
porque tienen algunas propiedades de los metales
y algunas propiedades de los no metales, pero en
general sí sabes si estas cosas son metales o
no metales a menudo puedes predecir qué tipo de
enlace se va a formar. Por ejemplo, si tengo un
enlace entre un metal y un no metal, ¿qué tipo de
vínculo crees que se formará? Bueno, cuando unes
un metal y un no metal -dimos un ejemplo de eso
en el primer video sobre enlaces-, digamos que un
metal como el sodio y un no metal como el cloro,
el cloro tomará un electrón, el sodio puede
perder uno, de modo que el átomo de cloro se
convertirá en un anión cloruro, luego el átomo
de sodio se convertirá en un catión y enseguida
se atraerán y se formará un enlace iónico. Esto
tiende a formar enlaces iónicos. ¿Qué pasaría
si tuviera un no metal con otro no metal? Un no
metal por dos, dos no metales unidos entre sí,
¿qué crees que va a pasar? Bueno lo vimos como
ejemplo en el primer video donde dijimos ¿qué
pasa si el oxígeno se une al oxígeno? Bueno, vimos
que era un enlace covalente y ese es generalmente
el caso cuando dos no metales forman un enlace,
éste será covalente. Y luego, por último pero
no menos importante, este podría ser el más obvio
de todos: ¿qué crees que sucede cuando tienes dos
metales formando un enlace? Bueno, puedes imaginar
que será un enlace metálico donde los dos aportan
electrones a este mar de electrones, y eso es lo
que los hace conducir la electricidad también y
ser maleables. Aquí los dejo. Hay excepciones de
todo lo que acabo de decir, pero en general estas
nociones le servirán bien, especialmente
en una clase introductoria de Química.